there are many rich muslims
who build huge houses
more than they
require
there is no zakat
on a house in which a person lives
if these houses were smaller the money
saved would be liable for zakat but
because they build huge houses they get
exempted from zakat
kindly comment
again
in this issue too the same difference of
opinion
normal ruling is that what is the basic
necessity the shelter the house which
require protection from the prying eyes
protection from heat cold rain
into the basic necessity and the house
in which you live is not liable for
zakat there's no difficult opinion but
in such cases as the questioner has
asked that he has a mansion
a person who may be having a wife and
three four children may require two
rooms three rooms five rooms six rooms
how many but if you have a mansion
which may be equivalent to ten
houses
then should you pay zakat or not so
again
most of the scholars
they say that the house in which you
live is not liable for zakat but it will
fall under the category of israel
as allah says in the quran in surah
israel chapter number 17 verse number 26
and 27
that be not a spencer be not extravagant
for verily a person who is a spendthrift
is brother of the devil
allah says in surah furqan chapter 25
verse number 67 that these are the
believers who are neither miser and
regardly neither the extravagant they
follow a middle path
so extravagance is haram in islam so
having such mentions is totally
prohibited people said salaam people say
it's makru whatever it is but yet
because they're living in it most of the
scholars say zakat need not be
this group of scholars they say that if
a person has a mansion
which is much more than what the basic
requirements multiple times more then
it's an excess wealth
and i agree with the questioner that you
could have bought ten houses
and lived in one so on nine houses there
have been zakah since this accessibility
this group of scholars say that zakat
should be paid even on that house a
person who owns many houses also
he should pay zakat on this and i agree
with that view
and even if it's not liable the person
is so rich
so even if he gives 2.5 percent it will
better for him it will
be a protection for him on the day of
judgement so i'm of the view that these
people should pay zakat
on the house
thank you very much dr zaki